disney princesses hail from the magic
kingdom
but we wanted to know what they would
look like with a makeover from the
wizarding world
we're imagining what some of our fave
princesses would look like as harry
potter characters
from pixie dust to potions these disney
princesses
are stunning in their hogwarts house
colors we've matched some princesses
with their famous
hp character counterparts in a magical
crossover we'd watch
over and over and over which house will
your favorite princess be sorted into
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
holy hippogriffs our talented artist
bippity boppity booped and transformed
our princesses
into our fave harry potter witches
better than any polyjuice potion
ever could which witch had the best look
is there another princess you'd like to
see glow up in the hogwarts halls
let us know in the comments section down
below and make sure to subscribe to the
things for more bewitching videos like
this
mischief managed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you